let me just tell you this baby cardi b  suffers a wardrobe malfunction on stage  at the mtv video music awards  [Music]  it was a big night for rapper cardi b  who served up some serious fashion a  white jumpsuit with a cape on the red  carpet a sparkly one piece for her  pre-show performance and this gown  during the awards that was so low cut it  nearly made a money move  the blush pink ensemble caught  everyone's attention as soon as she  stepped on stage to present demi  lovato's performance it was fine at  first but eventually cameras panned away  and cardi had to act fast coming from  las vegas i have to secure that show  yesterday give it up for demi lovato  performing sorry not sorry  safe to say cardi handled the situation  like a boss  you